[Music]
Intel's Arc battle mage b580 GPU
launches tomorrow for
$250 trying to fight the 300 class 4060
and the card is already massively
improved over Alchemist the first
attempt at ARC pretty low bar but has
hugely improved which is good to see so
we're going to be benchmarking this
today it's in a much better spot than
the last round by Price the b58 is
positioned to compete with nvidia's RTX
46300 card and amd's price parody RX
7600 at 250 both Nvidia and AMD have new
gpus launching in an early 2025 so
obviously we have no idea how those will
perform we don't have them we can't
account for them today but that is
something you should keep in mind if
you're looking at buying a GPU sometime
soon uh because there's going to be more
numbers on all that whenever they launch
what we can say though out of the gate
is that the b580 is far more reliable
Than The Alchemist cards were at launch
Intel has definitely improved it still
has issues and it was still shipping
driver updates until the last minute of
testing but the company has objectively
improved frame times have largely been
smoothed over they do however remain a
potential pain point for Intel in some
games idle power consumption is also a
pain point it's bit High however overall
value and throughput are competitive and
R tracing performance is particularly
competitive especially against the AMD
what's really interesting here and that
you're going to see the review is we
found that b580 does particularly well
as the resolution increases so uh the
4060 and the 7600 versus the b580 they
diverge as the resolution increases
where the b580 if it has a lead it
continues to gain a lead at say 4K and
uh likewise it starts to lose that lead
at 1080P and in situations where it's
not ahead it's able to sometimes help
close that Gap as the resolution
increases with the one big downside
being if it can't really quite play at
those higher resolutions it ends up
being mostly an academic exercise but it
really just depends on the game so it's
a really interesting review this is
packed with information I'm excited
about it because we have a complete
overhaul of our GPU test bench and we'll
talk about that today as well it's on a
9800 XD overclocked let's get into it
before that this video is brought to you
by thermal T and the tower 600 case the
tower 600 is a vertical case design with
thermal Tes unique showcase presentation
which stands out further with its
separate chassis stand kit that rotates
the case for an angled showpiece the
tower 600 is heavily ventilated around
the sides has a ton of radiator support
including up to 420 mm Solutions and
offers two GPU mounting options for
display and cooling optimization it also
comes in colors not commonly seen in
cases learn more about the tower 600 at
the link in the description below all
right so keeping in mind that the 50
Series is apparently around the corner
and whatever rdna thing is up next
should be as well let's get a quick
refresher on the pricing today right now
when we're filming this the b580 has an
MSRP of $250 and was already available
on pre-order on newag at this price the
pr prior Intel a770 is still available
for $230 to $280 for the 16 GB model the
a750 is at $200 to $240 the a580 is at
about $170 nvidia's RTX 460 is a main
competitor today typically at 300 bucks
alongside the RX 7600 at Price parody
with the b580 those will be the two key
comparisons we really focus on here one
step up the 4060 TI 8 GB and 7700 XT are
both around $400 to $420 right now
making them primary upgrade options one
step up now we already covered the b580
specs in a separate video we'll link
that below if you'd like to learn about
that the basics are on the screen in
this Slide the card launches ahead of
the b570 which will come out next month
the b580 is a relatively small 20 xe2
core configuration on the battl Mage
architecture that makes it smaller than
the a750 or the a770 in configuration
size Intel hasn't yet announced any 700
series cards in the battle mage series
The b580 has a 190 wat default TDP it
runs at least this one on a single 8 Pin
power connector of course board Partners
can kind of do whatever they want and
it's cut down to pcie 4.0 by 8 that is a
potential downside for people on Old
platforms but that's something we'd look
into separately in the future not in
this video today some Basics on the test
bench and methodologies first of all we
have a complete overhaul on our GP test
bench we've moved from an overclocked 12
700k which served us well for a while uh
who would have known that would have
been the best CPU Intel would launch for
years but we moved from that to a 9800
x2d this actually marks the first time
in our 16 or so year history that we are
using AMD as a permanent GPU bench
platform for the CPU and that's just
because the 98 x3d is so unbelievably
fast uh that it allows us to unbind the
GPU whever possible and try to make sure
we have the Headroom to hit the high
frame rates without bumping off of a CPU
bottleneck at least in as many
situations as as it's realistically
feasible so that's great gives us a lot
of room to run tests at low resolutions
and the 9800 activity we have
overclocked to 5.4 GHz we are running it
under a 420 mm Arctic liquid freezer 3
which allows us to run uh higher clocks
without any heat issues and then our
games list includes these not all of
these are shown in each review but they
are all tested we've added Dragon's
Dogma 2 from 2024 black myth Wukong from
2024 balers Gate 3 from 2023 now this
one will cut for the highend gpus like
if there's a 5090 but it's a good match
for the v580 Starfield from 2023 Final
Fantasy 14 Dawn tril uh Edition from
2024 cyber Punk Phantom Liberty from
20123 and all the others you see in this
list we've tested about 25 gpus for this
launch that list does not include the
RTX 480 the 480 super the 4070 TI or
super the 7900 XT or GRE and similar
high-end cards you can find scaling data
in our prior benchmarks for those like
in the Super Series reviews we added the
7900 XTX and 490 just for a ceiling and
the reason for the cuts is time it's
rolling into the end of the year and
with travel and everything we had to
make some decisions on what we wanted
and what we decided was it made more
sense to us to accommodate the GTX 1060
the GT X 1070 The gtx650 to try and give
a clearer picture for people who might
be upgrading we do have that data for
you uh you'll just check our 40 series
super reviews for all of that to get the
scaling roughly it won't be comparable
to the b580 here today but in most cases
it doesn't matter and we'll add those as
we go especially into January with the
high-end stuff launching so it's all
coming back you just got to give it for
the next round as far as cards with
multiple vram configurations we ran what
we consider to be the default or the
first launched vram config whenever an
option was present and then finally on
the side of the test bench we've added
power efficiency testing and idle power
consumption testing with calibrated
tools for this round this is the first
time we're really doing this in depth
for gpus now uh we have a lot more to
test still this video is huge already I
have to get on a plane in a couple hours
to go visit der BAU you'll learn more
about that soon and enough setup let's
just get into the benchmarks Final
Fantasy 14 Dawn Trails up now at 4K
first at 4K the Intel Arc b580 ran at 47
FPS average with lows exceptionally
close to the average the b580 has a
staggering lead of 28.6% over the RTX
460 which is elevated as compared to its
lead at 1440p and 1080p the RTX 460 is
behind and lows also although they
remain consistent and proportional with
its average the b580 also leads the 4060
TI at 15% ahead the a770 at 16 1.5% a750
by an impressive 28% the RX 7600 is
around the same price as the b580 but
struggles at 4K in this test at about 32
FPS average users of the GTX 1060 6 GB
card would experience an uplift of about
193% moving to the b580 with the 1070
seeing 110% and the 350 similar as we
saw in our 4060 review the 360 TI has a
massive memory bandwidth advantage over
its successors and embarrasses the 4060
and 4060 TI cards here from what we've
tested lately that's better than the
b580 that includes the $450 to $480 7800
XT at 22% improved and the RTX 470 non
super at 27% better among the flagships
of course everything above these that we
didn't test this round would also be
superior at 1440p the Gap Narrows in
some places the b580 is running at a
completely playable 86 FPS average with
good lows its lead over the lower cards
has decreased so it's 3.4% against the
460 TI 9% against the a770 down from
16.5% 19% over the a750 and the RTX 460
which is down from around 28% before and
31% over the 7600 the 7800 XD jumps up
to 40% lead from 22% previously so it's
gaining ground over the b580 the 470
jumps to 36% from 27% previously the
$400 RX 7700 XT leads at 98 FPS average
to 86 FPS average on the b580 but is
more expensive the b580 looks good here
overall despite a reduction in its lead
from 4K 1080p squishes everything
together and reduces the b580 is
Advantage the b580 at 124 FPS average is
now just 10 FPS ahead of the a770 and
RTX 460 or about 10% the b580 went from
28.6% lead at 4K to 19% at 1440p to now
10% at 1080p over the 4060 previously
the 6700 XT was margely below the b580
and in this chart 1080p it's ahead the
b580 also had nearly a 15% lead over the
4060 TI in our first chart but now is
behind the 460 TI leads at 133 FPS
average or an advantage of 7.6% which is
a pretty huge s Starfield is up now
tested at 1440p the b580 isn't as strong
in this one as it was elsewhere
Starfield is also a game that was not
functional on Arc at launch so running
at all is already better than last time
though that's a low bar the b580 ends up
behind the 7600 the 4060 the 46 TI in
this Benchmark it's beating the a770 the
a750 and a580 cards from Intel last gen
the 4060 leads by about 177% with the
4060 TI and an insurmountable 42% lead
the 7600 is closer at 5% ahead the
biggest downside here for INT is frame
time pacing int's b580 struggles with
0.1% lows and 1% lows comparatively
which are indicative of a deeper perf
frame problem that requires a frame time
plot to investigate we'll explore that
later in this video closer to the
conclusion at 1080p the b580 ran at 51
FPS average giving the RTX 460 at 10 f
PS average lead but an even bigger lead
in lows although the 4060 has an
advantage of 21% in average frame rate
the real difference is in frame time
pacing that we'll see closer to the end
the RX 7600 lead is now 4% with the 460
TI at 44% ahead Intel's b580 leads the
a770 by an impressive generational 16%
despite a lower core count configuration
that's a huge Improvement for Intel
against its own stuff it's leader for
the a750 is 27%
despite these gains the b580 is not that
competitive in Starfield let's move on
to the next one Resident Evil 4 at 4K is
pretty interesting the b580 roughly
matches the 4060 TI with a marginal
deficit on 0.1% lows the lead over the
4060 is massive benefiting the b580 by
31% in average FPS it also holds an
advantage in lows the lead over the 7600
is 24% with the generational lead over
the a580 and a750 alike impressive this
is a strong showing for Intel's b580 at
1440p the b580 maintains a competitive
position the card is fully playable at
85 FPS average with overall okay lows Al
be at lower proportionally versus the
neighboring a770 and 360 TI with the
resolution drop the 4060 TI now leads
the b580 by 7% from its rough
equivalence before b580 benefits from
its memory bandwidth at 4K the lead over
the 4060 is reduced to a still note
worthy 225% down from 31% previously the
7600 lead is reduced from 24% at 4K to
18% at 1440p 1080p weakens the b580 is
overall position the 4060 TI now moves
to 10% ahead the b580 is lead over the
4060 is reduced to 19% but that's still
a big lead most notably though we see
the frame times deviate more from the
average the 128 FPS average is
accompanied by 74 FPS and 63 FPS 1% .1%
lows with the b580 whereas
proportionally and based on neighbors
these figures should probably be closer
to the 100 to 110 FPS ter
the drop jumps out as different from the
rest balers Gate 3 is up now one of the
most played games in the last year so
Intel has to do well in these types of
critically acclaimed titles last round
we saw that Intel did better in Vulcan
with Ballers Gate 3 than it did with
dx11 but was still disadvantaged in both
apis with dx11 and 4K Ultra the b580 ran
at 45 FPS average the lows are reduced
versus its immediate Neighbors in the
460 and 7600 both of which would be
better experiences by frame times alone
despite all all looking approximately
equal in average FPS this is another one
for a frame time chart list at the end
the b580 improves on the a750 by 6% the
a580 by 21% and it falls behind the a770
in this one the arc cards are generally
less competitive in frame time
consistency in this game however they
have significantly improved in their
performance from a year ago here's 1440p
the b580 ran at 74 FPS average which is
completely playable in this game the
lows are also acceptable in an objective
sense it's not a bad experience but it's
also not as good as you'd get for
frametime pacing from the 3060 4060 or
6600 XT the 6600 xt's average frame rate
holds a 14% lead with the 460 at 8%
ahead breaking rank from a roughly tied
average at 4K the 7600 also climbs ahead
now matching the 6600 XT rather than the
b580 average FPS as we saw at 4K the
4060 TI is 35% ahead of the b580 with
its 100 FPS average generationally Intel
improves Over The Alchemist a750 by 7%
with a notable leap over the 62 FPS
average of the a580 in cyberpunk Phantom
Liberty at 1440p the b580 performs
overall well this is one of Intel's
strongest titles at 1440p and with ultra
settings without RT the b580 lands at 53
FPS average in one of our in-game tests
within one of the Cities not the
built-in Benchmark the b580 roughly
matches the 3070 although is lower in
0.1% lows in frame time consistency the
b580 leads the 4060 in average FPS by
36% the 7600 by a similarly large go and
the 4060 TI 8 GB model by 12% the 4060
TI has stronger 0.1% lows but not in a
way which we think is worth the cost
tradeoff at 1080p the b580 slips in the
ranks below the 4060 TI which also
carries a large advantage in 0.1% lows
the b580 technically leads the 4060 in
average FPS by 18% by the 4060 pulls
ahead and overall frame time consistency
the 7600 is in a similar boat black myth
Wukong is next this is one of the few
games where we use the built-in
Benchmark it's new to our test Suite
it's been pretty consistent dropping
settings would obviously increase the
frame rate but we're interested in the
scaling here at high settings broadly
speaking the b580 still has a slight
deficit in lows but a far less
noticeable one than in some of the other
games it's close enough to the 7600 and
the 3060 that the experience would feel
overall similar although technically
worse by measurement the RTX 460 holds a
significant lead in this test up at 19%
and 54 FPS average to 46 FPS average on
the b580 frame time consistency is also
better uh the 3060 TI leads the 4060 and
the b580 with the 4060 TI at 65 FPS
average or 42% ahead of the b580 the
b580 at least improved on the last
generation at 29% over the a750 and 38%
over the a580 Intel's making big
generational strides against itself here
at 1440p we're bordering on synthetic
test territory for the b580 but what
matters to us is the scaling not the raw
FPS at 35 FPS average the b580 allows
the 4060 Elite of 6.6% down from 19% at
1080p this is a huge swing in favor of
the b580 which continues to scale more
favorably as resolution increases it's
just a question of whether it's actually
playable at that resolution the 7600
Falls below the b580 and average FPS and
is roughly the same in lows the B 580
also leads the prior generation Flagship
from Intel the a770 which was at 30 FPS
average we're going to pick up the speed
here now that the patterns are
establishing dragon's dog with 2 is up
next for our CPU testing we Benchmark
inside the city to create an NPC
workload on the CPU for GPU testing we
test outside the city and in a GPU heavy
area with Fields water and structures at
1440p the b580 ran at 44 FPS average
with good lows the GPU does much better
here than in some of the prior tests and
it keeps up the pacing with the RTX 460
the 7600 460 and b580 are all
functionally equivalent in this grouping
the 3060 TI benefits from its memory
bandwidth and leads this group this is a
much better positioning for the b580
than the prior game at 1080p things
shake up and knock the b580 loose from
its rough equivalent with the 7600 and
the 4060 now the 4060 holds a 133% lead
and the 7600 has an 11% lead the b580
retains overall typical frame time
pacing which is good for Arc and it does
manage to H in there but again it's seen
some losses as the resolution comes down
d light 2 is next this one looks pretty
good for Arc including frame time
consistency the b580 runs at 63 FPS
average which has it ahead of the 460 TI
the 460 and the 7600 it's also ahead of
these devices in 1% and. 1% lows and
what's a major victory for Intel
considering some of its challenges and
losses in the other games the b580 ends
up between the 370 and the 6700 XT the
$400 7700 XT holds a lead and average
FPS of 12% here despite being 60% more
expensive this is one of the stronger
showings for Intel at 1080p the b580
continues its good performance by
outmatching the a770 and the 4060
however it loses ground to the 4060 TI
that it had outperformed at 1440p the 87
FPS average is well into playable
territory and Carries good lows with it
the die size is also much smaller than
an a770 so outperforming it is key here
Intel may be able to reduce some of its
cost per card which will help it compete
long term we're moving to rate tracing
benchmarks now these are not comparable
to the rasterized counterparts Resident
Evil 4 is up first this is a relatively
light workload for rate tracing and
isn't as distorted for one vendor or
another as some games are this first
chart is at 4K with Max RT but with FSR
set the quality for all devices we
validated other upscaling Solutions
across the RT suite and we found that
their performance is roughly identical
between FSR DLS s and xess where all
three exist or where even just two of
them exist so matching for just FSR
agnostically allows us to control for
image quality as well which is a concern
here because we're using FSR it's not
native resolution we don't use FSR in
our rasterized tests here's the 4K chart
the b580 ends up directly competing with
the RTX 4060 TI in the average frame
rate and in frame time consistency with
lows overall indicative of a comparable
frame to- frame interval to the 4060 TI
it's not far off from the 3070 Intel's
b580 leads the RTX 4060 by 21% at 50 fps
to 41 FPS average the improvement over
the a750 is similar and we need to run
the 7600 back through this one still but
the 7700 XT and the 6600 XT give an idea
for AMD positioning here's 1440p in this
test the Intel b580 runs at 75 FPS
average with overall good lows the 1% 0.
1% metrics are similar to what we see on
the 3060 TI which outperforms the b580
Intel's b580 manages to outperform the
RTX 460 still but this time only by 6%
including proportional frame times it
also outperforms the a770 71 FPS average
which was already relatively good for RT
especially for basically first try last
time amd's RX 7600 ran at 65 FPS average
giving the b580 nearly a 16% advantage
while costing about the same the RTX
4060 TI is 91 FPS average results out
does the b580 75 FPS average by 21% here
including scaling in the lows the 7700
XT pushes further ahead up at 106 FPS
average and both of these devices cost
about 60% more than the b580 at around
$400 plus or minus a bit for the 4060 TI
8 GB and the 7700 XT alike as tested
here at 1080P and with the same FSR and
RT settings Resident Evil 4 positions
the b580 now below the RTX 460 though
they're functionally tied it's losing
the advantage that we've now proven it
typically has at higher resolution so
that behavior is repeating from
rasterizing these two and the RX 7600
are closest in price with the 7600 down
at 85 FPS average and allowing the b580
a slight lead of 9% the 460 TI leads the
b580 by 29% with the 7500 XT 40% ahead
of battle mage overall Intel's
performance on this lighter RT test is
competitive especially for price and in
comparison to AMD steinl 2 is a heavier
RT workload than the last one and is
tested with FSR quality at 1080p the
b580 ran at 65 FPS average and held
consistent frame times it's a little
better than the a770 and similar in
average to the 3060 TI the 4060 TI leads
the b580 with its 73 FPS average result
a gain of 12% the b580 leads the 4060 by
133% and AMD falls behind in this test
with the 6700 XT now below the b580 and
the RTX 460 the b580 ends up with nearly
a 30 30% lead over the 6700 XT which is
a precarious spot for AMD the lead over
the RX 7600 45 FPS average is 44% here
in Dragon sgma 2 with Max RT and no
upscaling the b580 ran at 44 FPS average
with lows slightly lower than where they
should be the a770 leads the b580 and
lows and ties in the average amd's RX
7600 does better here than in cyber Punk
and black myth up at 53 FPS average and
outranking the B 580 by 20% the RTX 460
also outdoes the b580 and also
outperforms the 7600 frame time Pac in
landing at 54 FPS average battle mage is
doing okay but it doesn't have the same
Advantage it has in some of the earlier
tests at 1440p and RT with Dragon Dogma
2 the b580 ran at 36 FPS average and had
dips and lows compared to the
neighboring prior generation a series
gpus The 7600 leads the card now by
about 10% reducing its lead at 1080p the
RTX 4060 is in a similar position but
with better lows cyberpunk with medium
RT settings is less brutal on AMD than
Ultra something we showed in our last
round of reviews but remains one of the
heaviest RT loads and disproportionately
hard on AMD devices this is tested
without any upscaling the b580 did
overall well here its average frame rate
was competitive with the RTX 360 TI
despite lower 0.1% lows than it the 4060
struggles in this one with frame time
pacing and is erratic and unpredictable
with these settings the b580 has a much
better experience with the 3060 TI and
up even better still the 4060 TI also
struggles with frame time consistency as
illustrated by the 0.1% lows that draw
our attention to the problem this
appears to be an issue with memory
bandwidth especially as contrasted with
the 3060 TI which likely compounds with
the vram capacity in a massive loss for
AMD the b580 runs 62% ahead of the RX
7600 in average frame rate while also
maintaining Superior lows and frame time
pacing amd's closest card is the RX 7700
XT which is significantly more expensive
this is a repeat of what we saw with The
Alchemist cards last time where the a770
and a750 alike outperformed AMD 6700 XT
and 7600 we tried test an RT Ultra for
cyberpunk but unfortunately the system
hard locked with the b580 card for us
this Behavior did not occur on any of
the other 18 plus devices we test with
these settings and appears to be related
to battle mage black myth
is up next this is one of our
experimental charts which means we are
still researching it and we're still
vetting it so it's not completely up to
our full standards yet but we are at a
stage where we're ready to share the
data so that we can start sort of poking
at it to learn more as we continue to
build on the GPU tasting we just tried
to be clear in the disclosures of our
level of confidence for a new data set
so with an experimental chart it's
always a little lower this one is brutal
on anything that isn't Nvidia Intel also
had a last minute driver update for R
tracing performance in this game and at
10 0p with FSR set to Quality using High
raster settings and medium RT settings
the b580 ran at 34 FPS average with lows
where they should be Intel's last minute
driver change did nothing to our results
they were nearly identical so we're just
showing one set here we're not sure what
Intel thinks it changed but it did
nothing for us the b580 ranks alongside
the RX 7800 XT as AMD has serious
difficulties with this game Wukong is
similar in performance to cyberpunk for
the characteristics of behavior on AMD
or even a 4060 outperforms a 7900 xdx
for Intel it at least is doing better
comparatively than AMD but Nvidia has a
strangle hold here we'll move to some
quick zoomed in shots of the frame time
charts for some good and some bad
scenarios for the b58 there's a lot to
look at here but we're just going to
look at a couple we'll start with balers
Gate 3 at 4K this chart shows the
frame-to-frame interval on the vertical
axis and the frame on the horizontal
axis lower is better more consistent is
best although the b580 at times is lower
than the 4060 the card experiences
occasional but massive excursions from
the previous frame we're seeing some
jumps upwards of 20 milliseconds which
is noticeable but not necessarily
gamebreaking it depends on the frequency
of them in this case you'd notice they
do occur frequently enough that it pop
out Arc has improved substantially from
Alchemist in this specific regard but
it's clear that Intel still has work to
do in at least dx11 with this game
dlight 2 rasterized is one of the better
scenarios for Arc so we'll balance by
looking at that as well in this one the
b580 had better frame times across the
entire bench pass it's lower overall but
also doesn't experience any major
unexpected deviations unlike the
previous Ballers gate chart the b580 GPU
is exceptionally consistent in its frame
time pacing here the 4060 ends up worse
of the two devices tested in this chart
in this next one Nvidia and its RTX 460
are a victim of its own Creation in
cyberpunk with rt medium the RTX 460s
frame buffer and memory bandwidth cause
it to struggle resulting in frame time
spikes that in one case on this chart
exceed 120 milliseconds that's one tenth
of a second you're looking at the same
frame this massive Spike would result in
a stutter in game these stutters were
repeatable during play there's another
large Spike later in this run and they
also happen frequently in our other runs
the b580 did not exhibit this behavior
in this test and would be a better
experience Intel's memory choices
benefit the company here bandwith is one
of them but capacity also contributes
Starfield had some major consistency
issues run to run for Intel so we
actually only showing Intel for this
this shows two test passes from
Starfield at 1080p for the b580 in this
one you're seeing wildly inconsistent
frame pacing with a total range from 13
to 53 milliseconds there's no pattern to
it and frame delivery is overall erratic
making the experience less consistent
and allowing more micro stutter
behaviors to emerge d light too looked
much better for battle mage Final
Fantasy 14's up next in this one the
b580 did well overall but had slightly
reduced 0.1% lows versus the 3060 TI and
the 6700 XT as you saw in our previous
bar chart however it did better than the
4060 across the board in the frame time
chart for Final Fantasy we see an
incredibly flat line with only one major
spike that would hardly be noticeable
since it isn't repeating let's move on
to efficiency now we're getting into the
power consumption and power efficiency
measurements this part's actually really
cool cuz we've totally overhauled it for
this it's a huge rework uh is actually
something people have been requesting
for a long time so we're excited about
it we're taking a lot of our learnings
from CPU power efficiency testing and
we're applying them to gpus this is
something we consider in experimental
status that means that the charts and
the data although they meet our
publishing standards it's all new
methodology it's new testing it's a new
approach so that means that it hasn't
been through as thorough of a public
vetting process as or other data so
let's get into it for this testing we're
using a pmd2 hooked into a pcie slot
interposer and the pcie cables for 12vt
high power this pmd2 has been personally
Cali celebrated by Elmore from Elmore
labs for our work upon request and we've
had it validated against other
measurement devices including current
clamps we're isolating for just GPU
power here so this eliminates all other
testbench power draw this allows us a
clean and isolated feed of GPU Behavior
we haven't yet tested our full lineup of
gpus because this is all brand new
testing so we only have some of the most
relevant cards you'll have to check back
as we add more this chart is for idle
power draw on Windows desktop and
without any GPU tasks active the Intel
b580 pulled about 35 Watts when idle at
desktop which is a lot less than The
Alchemist gpus pulled up at 46 Watts 45
watts and 43 Watts but it's still higher
power than everything else Intel still
has an idle power consumption challenge
to overcome the RX 6600 for example
pulled only 5 Watts through the pcie
slot and the pcie cables combined when
idle which is impressive the 6600 XT was
similar at 6.2 Watts the 4060 is a
relevant comparison and far lower in
power consumption I down at 11 wats to
the b580 is 35 Watts or so this is an
area Intel will eventually need to
improve but no one will care about its
idle power draw if the performance isn't
good enough to Warrant a purchase in the
first place so we'll see if this
improves subsequently idle GPU power has
been requested by our audience for years
so we're happy to finally start
delivering it with this first look the
next chart is for balers Gate 3
efficiency at 1440p looking at
rasterization performance this is
measured in fps per watt which can be
thought of as frames per Jewel since
it's just frame per second per Jewels
per second higher is more efficient here
FPS per watt is easier to understand for
most people so we use that phrasing in
this test the RTX 460 TI has the best
FPS per watt performance up at 0.71 the
460 TI is about 37% more efficient
meaning its FPS per watt score is 37%
higher than the Intel b580 this is still
a massive generational Improvement for
Intel where it's a580 previously was way
down at 0.31 the b580 scores 68% higher
in fps per watt than the a580 and a750
which is near the 580 its total power
draw is about 141 Watts here the same as
the 4060 TI and so the reason its FPS
per watt is lower is because its frame
rate is simply lower the 4060 pulls 126
watts in this test and has a slightly
higher frame rate benefiting on both
sides of the equation we don't yet have
the RX 7600 in this lineup now we'll
look at one of the b580 best case
scenarios to balance the two this chart
is for Final Fantasy 14 at 1440p where
the card did well the b580 ends up
fourth on our list so far at 0.51 FPS
per watt ahead of the 7800 XT and behind
the 4060 the 4060 pulled 124 Watts here
putting it at 0.58 FPS per watt and
almost 14% more efficient than the b580
that's a good spot for the b580 despite
being less efficient and pulling more
power at 170 Watts the 4060 TI pulled
just 120 9 watt so it didn't leverage
its total power budget and was 27% more
efficient than the b580 against the last
generation the b580 is significantly
more efficient than the 6600 XT the 6600
the 360 TI and Intel own arc cards the
jump over the a750 alone is huge
especially since the Titan model from
Sparkle here has a boosted power budget
at 1080p the 490 and 4060 TI appear the
same because the 490 is completely CPU
bound here it can't perform any better
it doesn't have the room but it remains
in a relatively high power State the
b580 again ranks as less efficient than
the 4060 and more efficient than the
7800 XT and below the b580 pulled 161
Watts here in black myth w at 1080P and
without R tracing the b580 scored 0.3
FPS per watt and pulled 146 Watts which
has it significantly behind the RTX 460
at 0.4 FPS per watt and 121 Watts the
490 would rank higher if it could fully
stretch its legs for the same reasons
we've already discussed the b580 is
about equal to the 7800 XT once again in
Phantom Liberty with rate tracing and at
1080p the b580 manages to hold on to its
fourth place positioning in our current
limited lineup the lead over the 7800 XT
is now a massive 29% thanks to amd's
Performance issues in this title
dragging it down the 4060 maintains an
advantage of 15% over the b580 what's
clear is that Intel has drastically
improved on its a series performance so
Intel battle mage is way better than
Alchemist it's a it's a low bar but it's
a very important bar because if you go
look back at Alchemist uh it wasn't good
was not a good launch the drivers were
really terrible uh the software was
difficult to navigate it was broken in a
lot of cases the overlay was one of the
worst user experiences ever they've
removed the parts that really sucked
with it now there's some problems still
and there's going to be more that we
won't find because when you're two
generations into a GPU architecture like
this uh or gpus just period I should say
these are this is going to be a
community effort it's going to take uh a
lot of reviewers and a lot of users to
really root out the key problems but
based on our Alchemist experiences this
is at least not like that so Intel has
kept the improvements it's made over the
couple years since Alchemist launched
we've covered those and follow-ups uh
and it's applied them here which is a
good thing to see now this time around
we ran into a couple driver issues but
only one that complet prevented play and
again that was in cyberp Punk with rt
Ultra medium it was fine without RT it
was fine some reason RT Ultra in our
test environment uh the game just hard
it just crashed and that was something
that intel was able to confirm they have
some theories as to why it happens but
all we can really say is that out of the
18 plus cards that we tested with those
settings none of them had this issue
except for battle mage and so we've just
got to point to battle mage cuz we're
not able to reproduce it on anything
else but that was the only sort of major
driver issue we had uh we did have one
time where it hard crashed as in the
whole system restarted and we're not
sure exactly what caused that or when it
happened uh but again it was a a one-off
for battle mage and nothing else so
anyway those were the two major
instances now for an Nvidia or an AMD
launch where they have been doing this
for a long time that would be very
noteworthy it's noteworthy here two but
for a different reason because two is
like I think last time we we filed over
40 different bug uh reports and varying
severity issues with Alchemist so two's
two's good it's big Improvement this
review is already long so let's keep it
simple here's the key points we observed
that the b580 skills actually really
well as resolution increases so
especially at 4K and the games that
aren't heavy enough to eliminate that as
an option was is doing really well
unfortunately the card isn't so powerful
that 4K is playable in a lot of these
games but the behavior was consistent
with 1440p as well at 1080p we saw a
loss of advantage or sometimes a flip in
instances where the b580 was ahead of
the 4060 or the 7600 it might then be
behind them but it was generally trading
blows depending on the game sometimes
bigger gains or losses next Intel's
frame times are much better than they
were they avoid experience ruining
issues in almost all cases that is not a
concern this time around uh the battle
mage drivers still have some frame time
pacing problems in some games and tests
and are not overall superior but they
haven't improved enough that in
combination with a low enough price
point at $250 and Below they could be
overlooked depending on the game you
play also as a downside Intel's idle
power consumption remains High it has
improved massively but it's higher than
everyone else when idle still for the
most part Intel's efficiency in actual
gaming scenarios at least when those
games perform well for the battle mage
card have improved significantly and
it's actually competitive in some
situations with the likes of the 4060 uh
with the 7800 XT and things like that
now as the a750 went on massive fire
sales previously we'd sometimes
recommend it with heavy caveat and the
main one was that we never really felt
comfortable recommending it to the
general mainstream audience because we
feared that users without
troubleshooting experience or those who
have troubleshooting but either don't
have a second GPU that's not Intel or
patience would find it frustrating when
encountering games that simply don't
work Starfield for example just didn't
work when it launched on Arc now looking
back maybe they were doing you a favor
Starfield not the best received game the
point stands though battle mage has
improved on this front we feel much more
comfortable in general with people
buying a battl mage GPU as opposed to
Alchemist however we still have one
major caveat which is that this is still
only the second true generation of
Intel's modern dgpu so this is just my
reminder to you all that we can only
really report on what we've seen and you
have all the games we've tested all the
numbers uh what we have seen so far is
we were not really able to find other
than the uh instance I mentioned with rt
Ultra and cyberpunk any sort of
consistent experience ruining like
absolutely not this is a problem issues
uh at a driver level like last time now
I am 100% positive they exist and that's
why this section's in here so uh what
you're going to have to do is look
around at some other reviews and see if
anyone's dug anything up we don't really
talk to a lot of reviewers before these
launch they're all embargoed anyway so
probably something's out there that's
going to be the nature of the Beast for
a couple generations with Intel's cards
it's just it's going to be a fact of
life Nvidia and AMD have had basically
decades to get their stuff together and
Intel is just catching up so that's just
going to be how it is uh but we did not
have any major issues other than the one
and so we can only speak from our
experience which is that generally
speaking uh this is far better than it
was and I would feel a lot more
comfortable saying that if the pricing
makes sense when you're shopping and
sort of pending what happens with the
Next Generation the b580 actually does
make sense compared to some of its
competition it's a little game dependent
but that's a far better position than
intel was in so the b580 poses
considerable value in some situations as
compared to the RTX 460 and the RX 7600
it's not always the best and it does
trade with these cards but it's a
serious competitor this time we've got a
lot more work to do with this and we're
definitely going to be back with some
more testing probably be doing a tear
down of the card and you have all the
the numbers at this point to dig through
it we'd recommend again looking at other
people as well uh in particular for this
launch just because of all the stuff we
just talked about so for what we've seen
the Improvement is obvious and that's a
great thing now it's just going to be a
matter of continuing to follow up and
seeing how it develops we've got more to
test so check back for all that the next
big thing will be to see what happens in
January with Intel's competitors uh
there's a reason they chose now to
launch and it was to get in front of all
the new stuff and depending on how
greedy Nvidia or AMD might decide to be
at the price point and the class that
the b580 is in it could be either really
bad for p580 or really good for it so uh
we'll cover that as the time comes but
thanks for watching subscribe for more
I've got to get on a plane and go fly to
see D Bauer mitt
o in the middle of the the name there's
a there's an OCT so check back for that
coverage as well we'll see you all next
time